and i welcome you all to this meeting of
council
before i formally start the meeting
i invite my chaplain the reverend johnny
hill of ashland murder united reform
church
to lead us
in a thought for the day
thank you very much chris
um i suspect we will all have different
thoughts and opinions on the christian
church and rightly so
you might be wondering and which
particular church is that that i'm
speaking about
well i'm probably only qualified to
speak about my own church the united
reform church
i didn't grow up in the urc myself it's
a church i chose to join as an adult
and there are lots of reasons why i did
one of which is its very inclusive
stance on same-sex relationships being
in a same-sex marriage that's important
to me
but there's another reason the urc is a
united church and i suppose the clue is
in the name
but what does that mean well let me pick
up for a moment on the idea of which
church
at the last count there were
approximately thirty thousand
christian denominations and groupings of
churches i kid you not
and the reason why there are so many i
suppose is a matter of human nature
groups of christians disagree on matters
of faith and doctrine and very often end
up going their own way
probably not dissimilar to the way in
which people disagree over matters of
politics perhaps you know a thing or two
about that
the urc is a church which was founded in
response to the conviction that division
is a matter of human failure
because christ clearly called his
disciples his followers the church to be
united as one
it might seem obvious to you and i that
christians are called to unity and not
division
but we've not always acted like that was
true
this year the urc celebrates 50 years of
having brought together three very
different christian denominations and
that's something i'm quite proud of
now by no means am i saying that the urc
is perfect not by any stretch of the
imagination
but let me say this
the way the urc has preserved unity has
never been about seeking uniformity
nor by making everyone think and believe
exactly the same things
we value our diversity and believe it is
a strength rather than a weakness
so my sincere hope in sharing today is
that it's not come across as too preachy
or sanctimonious
though i do believe that somewhere in
the job description
but as a humble sharing of our
experience of seeking to overcome
division and difference not by power
but through dialogue
and we hope through love
i'm just going to share some words from
the bible which are put in a modern
uh format
you're familiar with the old written law
love your friend
and its unwritten companion hate your
enemy
i'm challenging that this is jesus
speaking
i'm telling you to love your enemies
let them bring out the best in you
not the worst
when someone gives you a hard time
respond with grace for then you are
working out of your true selves
this is what god does
he gives his best the sun to warm and
the rain to nourish
to everyone
regardless the good and bad the nice and
the not so nice
if all we do
is love the lovable
is that really an achievement
anybody can do that
in a word
what i am inviting you to be
is mature people
live generously and graciously towards
others
the way god lives towards you
amen
[Applause]
the move to apologies i have received
apologies for absence
from
councillors shirley proctor kevin
proctor
joanne bennett ben hartley lawrence
walsh karina carter and jed carter
can i ask if anyone is aware of any
other apologies to be noted
no thank you
a notice now about voting and broadcast
information
not all technical facilities are
available in the chamber
and you might find that some microphones
are not working
if that's the case we have roaming mics
on standby should anybody's not be
working
also because some units are not working
votes this evening will be by a show of
hands
the meeting is also being streamed live
on the council's committee meetings
youtube channel the whole of the meeting
will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items and this actively promotes
democratic engagement in accordance with
section 100a brackets 9 closed brackets
of the local government act
1972.
thank you
i'll now make a very brief announcement
about timekeeping the agenda this
evening is significantly long there is a
lot in it and although it's obviously
the beginning of the next municipal year
i would encourage everybody to be as
succinct as they possibly can in their
speeches whether that's concerning um
emotion whether that's concerning the
response to a question because as i'm
sure you've all seen we have a packed
agenda and we really want to get through
it all by half past nine
so moving on item one minutes
i move that the minutes of the annual
meeting held on the 25th of may 2022 be
taken as read and signed as a correct
record
is that seconded
seconded
thank you leader all in favor
thank you announcements
her majesty the queen's birthday honours
may we take this opportunity to
recognize those citizens and persons
connected with trafford who were named
in her majesty the queen's birthday
honours list
obes were awarded to
mr richard bevan of hales for services
to association football
mrs laura fatchi and miss mr neil faschi
of orchargum for services to cycling
professor samia nefti maziani of
alchingham for services to robotics
mbes were awarded to mrs rebecca
goodrich of urmston for services to
education and the community in
manchester
mr gary hall of altringham for services
to taekwando
mr sanja kumar vadira of altringham for
services to international trade
the british empire medal was awarded to
mrs helen bedford gay of sale for
services to people living with fibro
dysplasia ossificans progessiva and
their families
and mrs
michelle mchale of old trafford for
services to the community in trafford
and manchester particularly during coded
19
and i'm sure you'll join me in conveying
the council's congratulations for their
achievements and their richly deserved
recognition
members may also be aware that each year
the times educational supplement makes
prestigious awards to schools in several
different categories
this year one of trafford schools namely
lime tree primary academy was
shortlisted in two categories and went
on to win the award for scnd provision
in a mainstream setting one of the
judges commented that a unique element
of the school was the manner in which it
built partnerships to reach and wrap
around both child and family and i'm
sure again we would all wish to
congratulate the school and its staff on
receiving this award
moving on does the leader of the council
wish to make any announcements this
evening no thank you chad thank you
leader do the chairs of the scrutiny
committees have anything to announce on
behalf of their committees councillor
acton
i haven't even put my hand up then
can i just inform members that uh
scrutiny committee
uh some time ago set up a task and
finish group to scrutinize disability
access within the borough
and part of that work was to consider
how planning could play a big part in
addressing the public sector equality's
duty
scrutiny
set out recommendations in a report that
went before the
executive
meeting on monday to consider
that report and one of those
recommendations was to ensure that
planning services
makes the most of opportunities to
improve accessibility particularly
for people with disabilities within the
planning decisions
and i'm really pleased that the
executive accepted the recommendation
and the council will now ensure that our
local plans reflect the sentiments
around the recommendations
i think this is a
big step forward for the future and will
benefit many many people throughout the
borough that we represent
i'd like to put on record my thanks for
the task and finish group work and a
particular thanks to councillor barry
winstonly who chaired the task and
finished group and was very central in
developing
that report
and also my thanks go to the executive
who accepted the recommendations on
monday
i think one other thing that i wanted to
say
is that we also met with the
staffers of disability
group
in this town hall
about disability access
in the workplace
and
i think you will notice
that changes are being made in this town
hall
ensuring that uh there's
automatic doors so people can access the
building but also
looking at how we could help people with
hearing difficulties
through you know a loop system that
actually works and works well
and i think with sight problems
we have these little lights now
which
i've just learned
with the help of uh councillor western
here
how to switch it on
but but you will notice changes and i
think that um you know
obviously councillor hines
who has a
site problem uh finds it very very
difficult when it's when it's darker
and i think
i don't know how long she'd been on the
council but
she'd been asking for something around
better lighting and and so on and i
think all of these things that we're
trying to do within our public buildings
will be a big benefit to all the
workforce to others councillors
and i think
the wider
public of trafford so i i just wanted to
make those points thank you so thank
thank you council action i'm sure you
all would uh wish to thank the group
that took part in this and the progress
so far and what is to come further on
addressing the the situations that
you've mentioned
um
counsellor
denise weston you anything to report
no thank you thank you and councillor
wetton from
health scrutiny only to say that we've
compiled the program most of the program
for this year and um i'm looking forward
to some
interesting work
on the health scrutiny committee
thank you councillor wetton
uh we moved to questions now there are
nine questions and there's an awful lot
of business as i've said it has been
decided that because all the councillors
have received notice of all these
questions and they have already been
published on the council's public facing
website
the council's initiative questions
initially will be taken as read
and the executive member or lead member
appropriately will respond and then
follow there would be i imagine
supplementary questions
so we move to
um basically as i've said each
questioner has the right of a
supplementary question and and all
should be put and answered without
discussion those are the supplementaries
um
the first question is was from
councillor thompson and is councillor
ross the executive member who is to
respond to that thank you
thank you mayor and thank you councillor
thompson for your question i know
previous with previous exchanges we've
had at scrutiny and elsewhere that
you've been keeping a close impact on
the impact of inflation and how what
it's the impact is on having on our
council finances
um after a long period of stability
inflation has become an issue for the
first time in a generation particularly
as a result of rising fuel and energy
prices you will also be there without
the support from central central
government that this year's pay award
will also have an impact on our current
and future budgets
from a financial perspective and in
response to pressures emerging during
this year's budget i announced the
creation of an inflation risk reserve in
june which now holds six million pounds
in respect of energy costs which
normally cost us 1.6 million a year we
are expecting those costs to double and
we're about to launch an energy saving
scheme across our council buildings
where we can we are pre-purchasing
materials to maintain supply and
avoiding cost pressures an example of
this being our street lighting columns
and we're also trying to promote more
green travel with some electric bikes
being used by some of our frontline
workers i hope that answers your
question councilor thompson
councillor thompson do you have a
supplementary question
yes i do thank you um
following on from that what assistance
are we likely to get from central
government
thank you may um i wish council thompson
i had an answer to that at the moment
sadly this government is somewhat
distracted by other things and are
missing what is a crisis not just in
local councils across the country but
households businesses both in the
private and public sector um
what i will do as a result of the the
pressures that we do face and i know
that it's the same across local councils
in england wales and indeed in scotland
is i will write to ministers and i'll
make sure you see sight of the letter i
write expressing our concern as a
council about the impact that inflation
is having on our day-to-day budget thank
you
the second question came from councillor
chalkin and it is the executive member
councillor patel to respond to that
question thank you thank you thank you
councillor chalking for your excellent
question
this is an area we're looking into
the council will commit to including
greenleaf's green clauses in our new
leases and lease renewals that are
appropriate and proportionate to each
property where possible for existing
leases the council will commit to
discussions with tenants where possible
and at the appropriate time noting that
any changes to existing leases would
need to have to be made through mutual
agreement
in addition the council is currently
reviewing its estate and decarbonisation
programme to look at all our property
portfolio and where green measures can
be applied
the council is currently preparing a
10-year estate strategy and will
incorporate plans and a programme for
decarbonisation
green measures across the whole estate
thank you
councillor chalkin do you have a
supplementary question uh no
supplementary sir
moving on the third question is from
councillor brophy and it is councillor
adsed executive member for environmental
and regulatory services would you like
to respond please
uh thank you matt if i could
just sit down a bit it's the easier
because
the
comments are actually on the computer i
hope that's fine by yourself yeah uh
hedge maintenance can be a
time-consuming operation that needs to
take account of ground conditions
wildlife and highway safety where road
safety is not jeopardized hedge
maintenance will be carried out during
january to march for the following
reasons it reduces the chance of
disturbance to breeding birds
nesting birds are given legal protection
under the wildlife and countryside act
one trafford a name is ground
maintenance teams are adapting their
operations to accommodate and support
wildlife wind traffic but
at the same time take account of the
growing hedge rolls that require regular
maintenance part of this adaptation has
been to introduce a tractor-side arm
flail which will allow for a firm
cutting back on sites
that are identified as potentially
causing obstruction to the highway
officers from the grounds maintenance
team as
highlighted have met with councillor
and coastline minis at the groveland
site and agreed a scheduled day for the
hedge to be hard cut back using the new
trapped up mounted flail the challenge
for the team will be allowing from
non-cutting
of these hedges during the month march
to september which is nesting season the
challenge is that the hedges
experience their main growth during
these months and striking the right
balance between achieving sufficient cut
back
and with hand-held edges
cutters i should say has caused problems
in the past but we're attracted mounted
sardar on flail that's now available the
teams are confident that they can
deliver the service going forward thank
you
councillor brophy do you have a
supplementary question
uh thank you councillor i'd said for
your reply to my question
i think you highlighted a key point
there because the question is about road
safety so we all understand the issue of
wildlife nobody wants to see hedges cut
when it's going to disturb wildlife and
nesting birds so that isn't really where
we're coming from here the question is
is this particular hedge has been a
problem for the last decade or two i've
been a councillor in the area and the
the pave the pavement is completely
obstructed by hedge now so the question
is this flailing is useful to hear about
that's a new thing that's come on
could you answer the question on what's
the criteria for this flailing
how widespread is that going to be
across trafford
and is this new schedule going to be
incorporated in the regular maintenance
schedule or is it just a one-off thing
that's happening in this particular
instance thank you
sorry councillor ed said you would like
would like to respond thank you
thank you for your supplementary
question counselor broadly yes just to
confirm that
the device will be used quite regularly
from now on but i can't say which parts
it will be using what the criteria is
obviously every hedge roll across the
board which is in part or indeed other
council land is completely different so
it's just finding the suitability one so
i mean uh i think you've done the right
thing in arranging a site meeting that
was the right thing to do i think
talking about it here isn't probably the
solution to it and the device which is
problem you can always contact myself uh
some members do already and we can
arrange things like site meetings and
actually talk about them on site where
we can actually deal with the problems
there i think that's the answer please
thank you thank you and thank you
thank you council outside the next
question is uh from councillor duncan
and again the response is from
councillor at head as a responsible
executive member could you respond
please
thank you uh
since june 2021 there have been 77
requests we see for 20 speed limit zones
across trafford investigations of the
top 10 schemes
that meet the matrix of priorities is
underway and suitable measures will be
designed and sorted upon following the
assessment of speed surveys that have
been undertaken
by tftm
design will involve in the main lining
and signing with potential physical
measures if needed with consultation on
the proposals and traffic regulation
order needed for each location
thereafter the process can take between
six and nine months or longer
if there are objections a list of
proposals will be published on the
website in the next month or so
following the speed survey assessment it
is likely
that with the approved budget and forty
thousand pounds that four or five
smaller schemes will be undertaken each
year depending on the size of the scheme
and the design requirements and hence
there will be a need for rolling
programmer schemes moving forward
thank you
thank you councillor i'd said councillor
duncan do you have a supplementary
question
yes i do thank you
thank you councillor adset for his
response
please could he now advise why on
nourish road sale
where existing speed limits are
constantly exceeded
there is no safe crossing place between
brooklyn road and craddock road
this in turn means that pupils
living on south of norrish road
attending brooklyn's primary school and
cell grammar school are often being
driven to school because
the option of walking is unsafe and this
in turn significantly increases traffic
congestion particularly during school
run thank you
thank you for your supplementary
question i would suggest the first
instance that obviously you raise this
with officers to look at because that's
more of a case where there is need for a
crossing patrol in the 20s zone by
sounds of it there are a lot of problems
there but i think as i'll say later 20
zones are ideal in some locations but
they're not suitable in every case and
they're also i've done other solutions
that can be looked at to address such
problems now off the top head here i
don't know that particular site here and
obviously when something has raised me i
do tend to look at those sites and they
are just officially suggesting first
instance that you do raise the swift
officers and they can be looked at there
after thank you
thank you councillor adser for that
response i would like to just remind
everybody when they are standing to
speak to use the microphones and clearly
as per councillor brophy if yours is not
working do request one of the roving
microphones we moved to the fifth
question which was raised by councillor
ennis and the response is with
councillor right uh as executive member
could you respond please councillor
wright uh thank you chair and thank you
council ernest for your question as at
the 30th of june this year there were 7
092
people officially registered for
re-housing on the trafford register
thank you
councillor ennis do you have a
supplementary question
yeah thank you mr mayor trafford housing
trust have made me aware that in a
number of cases where a vacant property
needs structural work or where there
would be prohibitive costs incurred in
the re-letting of a property uh the
standing policy is to sell that property
privately so could the executive member
please write to me to tell me how many
social properties in trafford have been
sold privately under that policy in the
last year
i'm more than happy to write to you on
that basis the the information will
obviously come from trafford housing
trust
themselves because they own the
properties um
but just to give you um we obviously do
have the empty home strategy at trafford
as well which i'm sure you're aware of
which we have made some significant
progress on the next few months but i'm
more than happy to fill you in on those
details thank you thank you councillor
right the next question came from
councillor wetton councillor i'd said
again to respond to this as it falls
within your executive portfolio thank
you
with reference to the six
recommendations offered by living
streets trafford are currently
supporting these priorities to assist
with clearing clutter on the highway by
applying minimum width of 1.8 meters in
footways
the width is being used in design and
placement of any new street furniture
such as ev charge points signs and
street lights and columns the guidance
included in any license is replacement
of any table and chairs also uses the
1.8
meter minimum width these scooters are
not currently within traffic however
the buy power scheme which is rolling
out from the autumn and indeed any
future easter arrangements agreement
we'll be working to a minimum of 1.8
metres but the majority of areas chosen
today for baikai are placed in locations
that have been more than 1.8 metres to
avoid high football areas trafford are
also looking to default to the highway
at every opportunity
during design and maintenance of the
highway to ensure pedestrian access
is prioritized and this also reduces
further maintenance costs examples of
current practices include removal of
redundant signs and relocating blank
columns to the rear footways the trees
and hedges that have the potential to
overhang are monitored during routine
highway safety inspections and
enforcement actions taken whether it's
an encroachment until the payment
coupled with routine hedge pruning
that's been taken on council on land
with newly purchased flail should ensure
that footways are cleared from
instructions
banning of a board would lead would need
to be considered as part of a policy
agreement we look relocating to
obstacles the latent constructions even
the use of a board is a long-standing
problem that is difficult to enforce in
some locations due to shared land
ownership in front of business premises
within the highway the requirement is
currently to ensure a minimum of one
point eight weeks is available for
pedestrians and public footwear thank
you
thank you councillor outside councillor
wetton do you have a supplementary
question
yes thank you um
thank you cancer had said for that reply
and it sounds like the
flail was
acquired just in time
but um the six recommendations from
living streets are very straightforward
and whilst taking steps to clear the
streets of physical clutter
will the council also take
greater steps to clear the illegally
placed banners
often on publicly owned railings
which not only blight the visual aspects
of our communities but also present
dangerous distractions and obscure sight
lines for road users thank you
thank you councillor wetton councillor
ted respond perhaps thank you uh for
your supplementary question
councilwedding uh yes i mean that we
could we can take action in appropriate
cases but we actually have been speaking
with a highway team and where possible
where they see
illegal fly posting on street furniture
that we have actually asked operators
where possible to try and remove these
if they're the right tools safely to do
so i would also suggest obviously that
you actually do report such incidents
and
and
that can actually then be removed we do
try and look i have actually discussed
with officers about the possibility in
the past actually taking action against
people doing these types of flight
problems the problem is however
in order to do the court process you
have to actually have legal evidence
that would put that the people
that the scientists have actually put it
there and and in law that is not always
possible as you appreciate so it's very
frustrating and i share those concerns
so much so and it's something that
obviously we would actually like the
government to legislate for
but as things stand if you do have a
particular problems please do report
them and if there are problems with that
obviously you can't copy me into
messages thank you
thank you councillor ads head we move on
question seven is the first question
from councillor holden and it is council
a new lead member for education to
respond please thank you
thank you chair thank you council holden
for your question
the figures i have from democratic
services who support some appeals if
schools buy in their services it's
important to note that this is not a
complete picture as 11 of the 19
secondary schools administer their own
appeals
equally some of these numbers may be
duplicates as the same people may submit
appeals to multiple grammar schools and
some of the grammar school appeals will
be for children that have not qualified
and are appealing against the assessment
outcome
the number of appeals from september the
1st 2021 until today are
appeals for year 7 places are 185
appeals for in-year places are 91 and
these include applications for sixth
form places
thank you thank you chair
thank you councillor new councillor
holden you have a supplementary question
yes i do thank you and thank you for the
the answer it was a little
less
clear than my very simple question uh
was aimed to
create but we are where we are
55 of those
appeals were for one single school
the secondary school in my ward
10 of those appeals i personally along
with probably some of
the other members attended with the
families
i'd like to know what i can tell
keon
elsa donna and all the other children
who i've seen crying
with their parents
distraught
traumatized about their separation from
their friends
what plans can i take back to them to
tell them that this council has
to allow children to attend primary
schools
within their community to move on to
secondary schools in their community
so that we don't have to spend the
amount of time that we spend every year
going into the schools and doing the
presentations on their behalf to try and
get them some special places
thank you
thank you councillor holden uh
councillor new to respond thank you
thank you for that councillor holden i
will um write to you tomorrow with a
fully a full explanation for that thank
you
thank you moving on question eight is
councillor holden's second question and
it is councillor ad said again to
respond to this as the executive member
appropriate thank you thank you uh
and council holden yeah the weedspay
program ordinarily takes eight weeks to
complete however the contractor is
looking to bring in additional resources
if available to accelerate this program
to ensure it is on track for the
original completion date all being well
with the weather the program should be
completed by the end of september if not
before
thank you councillor outside councillor
holden do you have a supplementary
question yes i do mr smith thank you
thank you for that uh that answer this
question was
what came into my mind because of some
genuine concerns
there has been
as you're aware i hope you're aware
a considerable and successful rewilding
program within saint mary's ward
the kerbs the gutters
the parks or surrounds to parks have
been left untouched and sprayed for
many many months
we've even succeeded as a council in
getting a small crop of wheat growing in
a gutter
on the main bus route between sail west
at the center of sail
will
subsequent spraying
be done so that we can avoid this
embarrassment or are we going to leave
it over the winter just in case
some of the rewiring process hasn't
completed
thank you councillor holden uh
councillor had said can you respond to
that supplementary question
thank you for your supplementary
question obviously a couple of years ago
we did actually move to actually uh with
agreement of all parties to one spray to
cut down on the damage that the weed
space due to the environment
and indeed parks and green space
themselves actually have no weed space
on them now so it's obviously but we was
obviously quite concerned when we're
told it's being put back a fortnight and
we've actually raised with amy those
concerns at the partnership board just
live away
and making sure that measures will be
taken next year to ensure that scheme is
brought forward and need other measures
but in interim we have been putting
pressure on amy to ensure that we are
trying to complete it as soon as
possible now obviously if there are
particular problems that then you can
speak with officers to ensure that it is
done but i'm confident that the
programmer set up will actually deal
with that that now i'm looking at some
of the locations and look at some of the
streets that know nearly but whilst
some weeds are actually quit really
quite bad and can damage the footpaths
and it is very important that we deal
with them in some cases there are out of
some water so far there are some nice
flowers growing so i'm not opposed that
but obviously the weed spraying program
will actually deal with those really
hard weeds i did comment a few years ago
that some of the weeds can actually
damage footpaths and street furniture
not dealt with so so the program that we
using will actually deal with that and i
know from concerns from other residents
that not all areas wish to use weed
spray and we've actually said but
probably that that's the most resident
groups of residents in those areas want
to talk about taking over that program
we're actually happy to talk to them
about doing that sort of work as well so
everybody wants to each be on their road
we have to talk to people so there's
lots of ways of dealing with this and
particularly want to come and speak to
us and you won't have to chat afterwards
write another meeting with practice look
at that program but the weed spraying
program will deal with the problems of
the winter it is so uh although it is
actually a reduced program it will
actually deal with the problems as they
are together with the combined street
cleaning work over the autumn we should
see it out thank you
thank you councillor i'd say for that
response we now move to the last
question of the evening which was placed
by councillor taylor could counsel and
you as a lead member respond to this
question thank you
thank you chair and thank you councillor
taylor for this question it's really
appreciated
the council has received further funding
by the household support fund hsf to
support vulnerable families and have
extended the 15 pounds per week child
award over the summer holidays to
families in receipt of free school meals
and or council tax support
the funding has been extended to the
31st of march 2023 and therefore support
will continue in the october december
and february holidays in addition there
is a school holidays activities and food
programme which is also known as haf and
this is shared through the family
information service and traffic
directory
for the dfe funded holiday activity
programme haf 21 providers have been
commissioned to deliver holiday
activities for school-aged children at
this point we anticipate providing
approximately 2 500 places including
some scent provision
the provision is primarily for children
in receipt of free school meals and the
provision is free at the point of entry
and all participants will receive a meal
as part of their attendance thank you
thank you chair
thank you councillor new uh councillor
taylor do you have a supplementary
question
um thank you mr met and thank you very
much councillor new for your
comprehensive answer i think you have
provided um most of the uh detail within
your answer um because i was going to
ask how many children are being
supported but i think you have um
provided that i think it's really um
gratifying to hear that this funding
will continue um because obviously with
the loss of the 20 pounds of um
universal credit uplift and also the
prospect of a hike in energy bills i
think many families will continue to
feel significant financial strain so i
think that's um it's
um good to hear that that funding will
continue thank you for your very
comprehensive answer
thank you councillor taylor uh we moved
to item four petition new street
altering them item four is a petition to
create a 20 mile an hour zone in new
street altringum which received 519
signatures and in accordance with the
council's petition scheme organisers of
the petition are allowed to speak to the
petition for five minutes and here with
us this evening are two new street
residents louise padmore and john paul
mobley
following their introduction the
petition will be debated by council for
a maximum of 15 minutes as is the agreed
practice for petitions at council
speeches are normally limited to one
member from each of the groups and since
there is only 15 minutes allowed for the
debate each group will be allowed three
minutes and 45 seconds following the
debate the leader of the council will
then summarize the council's response
if council consents to the arrangements
i will now invite the organizers to
introduce the petition and their five
minutes will be split
i'll take it we're okay with that
yes right so who would like to go first
please is it
it's mr
mr mobley thank you
thank you very much good evening ladies
and gentlemen my name is john paul
mobley i'm 28 years old and i've lived
on new street in altringham for the last
three and a half years following a
petition which was signed by over 500
people from the local area
i'm here with my neighbor louise who
you'll hear from in a moment to ask you
to create a 20 miles per hour zone for
the whole of new street in ultraingham
the safety of those who live work and go
to school either on or very close to new
street depends on it new street is in
the centre of ultraman running from
regent road to the downs while the width
of the street is still very much in the
c19 the types of vehicle using the road
is very much c21 i.e large suvs fast
sports cars and increasingly also hgvs
as you can see from the circulated
photograph
particularly in the upper section of the
street the existing infrastructure is
not suitable to vehicles of this nature
passing through at 30 miles an hour or
more
although there is only a raised pavement
on one side of the road cars speed along
this section without the fear of
oncoming traffic
we appreciate the council has previously
recognised this by installing bollards
in a speed bump at the start of this
one-way section but further action is
needed and a 20 miles per hour
restriction is the logical extension to
these restrictions
there will also be sustainability and
environmental benefits
through the reduction of emissions and
improved air quality there is of course
not much time to be gained by going up a
short street at 20 miles an hour as
opposed to 30 miles an hour
the existing 30 miles per hour limit is
too fast for a road of this nature and
drivers often exceed even this the
non-curbed unraised pavement so at road
level in upper new street is on the side
of the street with driveways over the
years there have been multiple near
collisions between cars and pedestrians
and leaving these driveways into fast
oncoming traffic is extremely dangerous
thanks to the market house and the
regeneration that that brought the last
five to ten years has seen altringham
transform from a commuter town into a
destination in itself
as such development has accelerated and
we currently have two ongoing
construction projects at the north end
of new street alone including a
multi-story car park with another
large-scale project to demolish dozens
of flats and replace them with
apartments and townhouses curling
currently at the planning consultation
stage
for these reasons traffic has increased
dramatically and will only continue to
do so
in short the inappropriate 20 miles per
hour speed limit continues to be ignored
by drivers who use new street as a rat
run through to the downs and towards
hail
a 20 miles per hour speed limit on new
street would undoubtedly have a positive
environmental impact reduce noise
vibration and emissions and make the
street much safer for residents
motorists and the many pedestrians who
use the street as a route into town
alike
as town centres high streets and
residential areas across the uk are
implementing 20 miles per hour speed
limits please consider our safety and do
the same for new street and implement
appropriate signage to warn drivers
thank you mr mobile uh mustafa i think
you've nicked 30 seconds of your
the other lady's time so uh can we now
hear from louise padmore ms padmore
thank you thank you my name is louise
i've lived on new street for the past
two years i'm with my partner and our
four-year-old son and we actually
relocated to ultra gum from london and
the big motivation for that was actually
to provide a better and safer
environment for our son
and yet each day we find ourselves
fearful of leaving our own front door
and trying to get into our car
on new street the parking provision is
on street we don't have a driveway which
means that in order to get my son in and
out of the car i have to do so at speed
in order to avoid us or the car door
being clipped by a speeding passing car
on numerous occasions i've had to halt
the process of getting him safely in his
car seat in order to pull the door and
us out of the way of these speeding
vehicles
this rushed and hasty process often
leaves me filled with anxiety
about the experience but also then as to
whether i've then safely secured him in
the car
the same panic issues each time we leave
the house on foot which we do each day
to walk to nursery
we only have a small front path and a
gate leading directly then on onto the
road
so every time we leave the house or the
front door is opened we must anxiously
remind our son to stand still hold our
hand and
there's a fair bit of panic
but obviously this issue isn't limited
to just myself there are many other
vulnerable groups who use the street
each day
another of those is the groups of school
children on route to ultragum grammar
school for girls
the girls walk in groups of friends
unaccompanied by adults at the busiest
time of day and when vehicles are using
the street as a cut through during rush
hour the combination of the very narrow
pavement as shown in the photos and as
jp mentioned plus the large groups of
children plus the speeding vehicles is
quite frankly terrifying
other vulnerable groups for whom this is
an issue
are they elderly and disabled who are
less able to hastily get out of the way
of the speeding vehicles and also many
parents with young children in prams who
regularly use the street right thank you
thank you thank you miss padmore that's
the five minutes but well spoken each of
you um can't move now ask
councillor ad said as the executive
member for environmental and regulatory
service uh i invite you now to respond
on behalf of the labour group thank you
council ads thank you
i'd like to thank john paul and louise
for bringing the petition to council
this evening and sharing with us the
consultant on behalf of local people
from avenue street
i can say we take all sorts of concerns
very seriously i am aware that response
with an update should be with you
following this evening's meeting
further to that point understand that an
assessment of the area has already taken
place at location including the looking
at the road layout the physical
environment as well as pedestrian and
vehicle movements and that will be used
to do further assessment work of the air
but in taking this matter forward
each year numerous requests are received
for all forms of vote safety measures on
hallway not just 20 zones requests will
also receive for measures such as yellow
lines pedestrian crossings and drop
crossing points for costumes
and these all have to be carefully
looked at fully considered and assessed
and those that scored the highest from
the assessment
and therefore most rights have the most
beneficial impact on local communities
and then looked at more detail to
considered for the capital programme
each year as part of this assessment as
well as looking at the location which
can include things such as schools parks
busy junctions and of course any action
record it can include also looking at
potential for alternative type of
schemes 20 zones in the right location
can work really well however they do not
necessarily solve all the problems and
they do need to be self-enforcing the
physical measures to be affected in most
cases in some cases alternative type
schemes may actually be more beneficial
to a particular street i'm aware that's
part of the assessment work for the
location it did include some c speed
survey work and understand that this
showed the average speed in the area to
be around 20 miles per hour however
further work and further assessment will
need to be carried out as part of the
review and indeed that all sorts of
requests have to go through each year to
enable us to draw proposals for the
kafka program i can confirm that new
street has been added to that list and
will be considered alongside the other
schemes as we draw priorities for the
capital programme work so again i'd like
to thank you for bringing this petition
to us this evening and highlighting the
concerns of local veterans and i was
sure you'll be given our fullest
consideration thank you
thank you councillor i'd said
is there a speaker on behalf of the
conservative group councillor morgan
thank you mr mayor um congratulations to
the petitioners on well done on
excellent speeches um the conservative
group absolutely support the petition
clearly residential areas like new
street and alternate need to be 20 miles
an hour
however and in a bit of deja vu
misdemeanor exactly a year ago i'm going
to use my speech to call on the
executives to go a bit further than new
street
yes we support school streets and other
speed calming measures but we need to go
further
um children play outside more than just
schools children are put into cars on
lots of residential roads and our
elderly residents cross residential
roads
and we so i asked the executive to have
more ambition and to bring in more
safety on all of our residential roads
and to bring in a policy of 20 mile
assumption on residential roads thank
you
thank you councillor morgan do we have a
speaker to respond on behalf of the
liberal democrat group you do councillor
newgross
can i begin by thanking louise and john
paul for their efforts bringing this
petition tonight
the liberal democrats have long held 20
mile an hour as a campaign goal in fact
we were the first group
in trafford to bring a motion to this
council to uh restrict residential
streets to 20 miles an hour across the
borough
i would like it noted that it was the
conservative leading group at the time
that voted that down
as a lifelong resident of altringham i
know new street and the particular
layout and issues of this road well
as such the liberal democratic group
enthusiastically support the petition
before us
thank you councillor newgross and we
have councillor coggins who will speak
on behalf of the green party please
thank you
thank you mayor and thank you to louise
and jp and all those involved for
bringing this petition um i want to
start not by talking about new street
but talking about another area some of
you might know um old street in nearby
town of ultrinford and in old street
they actually have a problem a bit
related to the one in new street and
where vehicles are only allowed travel
at 20 miles an hour and it causes delays
of several seconds every time people
have to drive down their street and so
they do want a higher speed limit
introduced to save time
and to ask cars and trucks to speed past
their doorways at 30 miles an hour
now old street you might have guessed
doesn't exist and you've guessed that
because there aren't residential streets
where people have slowly driving cars
and want faster driving cars
and if we didn't have cars going at 30
miles an hour on new street nobody would
be asking for it and if we brought a
proposition like the old street
proposition into this chamber not one of
you would vote for it so 30 mile per
hour limits where people live are a
historical accident in fact they're more
than that they're a historical mistake
and we have an opportunity and indeed a
responsibility to rectify that mistake
now new street is unique in many ways
and it's got a great community spirit
it's heavily used by people walking to
and from the town centre and residents
there have been trying to make their
roads safer for 30 years
and in case you think that driving on
new street is not as bad as we've made
out the bollards you can see in the
picture and others further down the
street we asked in 2019 and we're told
they had been replaced roughly three to
four times a year in the previous three
years at a cost of 332 pounds per
ballard and that's happened many many
times since then
so there's many ways in which new street
is unique but there are many other ways
which is not unique and the thing is we
have discussed this issue with residents
on the doorstep extensively and we know
that people want lower speeds where they
live as far back as 2011 the british
attitude survey showed that over
two-thirds of people want a 20-mile an
hour speed limit where they live
we've heard from councillor ad said that
the council is looking at doing four to
five small schemes per year this is an
absolute waste of council money and far
more expensive than doing it all at once
we could have a default speed limit in
trafford of 20 miles an hour where
people live like many towns cities and
other boroughs across the country are
doing
so we in the green party are calling for
20 mile an hour limits not just on new
street not just in nottingham but right
across trafford across all of our front
doors and i know that there are many
things that the council wants to do and
they're often stimmed by a lack of funds
or by not having the power to change
but this one is in your gift this isn't
expensive and it is something that
trafford residents want
the evidence from around the world is
convincing that reducing speed limits
saves lives
so please stop cars driving over 20
miles an hour on new street and across
trafford outside our homes thank you
thank you councillor
coggins
finally will the leader of the council
now summarize for the council and our
guests this evening
what will now happen with the petition
going forward thank you
thank you chair and i would add my
thanks to the two petitioners for um
bringing this forward as councillor
assad has said
this will be given consideration as part
of
the programme of works that is brought
forward through the capital programme
each year which includes a budget for 20
mile per hour
zones there is of course
a need to
measure it against the other schemes
that have been put forward for
consideration clearly
we are not able to say because a
petition comes that will mean that it is
considered to be more urgent than a
scheme that is
required for safety purposes perhaps
over and above the assessment made on
new street councillor ad said
did point out and i think it is
important to just give consideration to
this that the average speed of vehicles
on new street is already around 20 miles
per hour but of course i accept that
that does not prevent
idiots well you're shaking your head and
i don't wish to get into a dialogue with
a member of the public chair because
that would be inappropriate but that has
been surveyed and is fact and what i was
about to say was that that does not stop
the occasional idiot from driving down
the road at more than the legal speed
limit currently 30 but of course neither
would a 20 mile per hour sign and that
is the problem here actually because we
heard
um that people
do occasionally travel far too quickly
along new street 20 mile per hour zones
will not stop somebody who is determined
to do that from doing that
that is not me saying that this scheme
will not happen that is not me saying
that there is not budget for 20 mile per
hour zones but it is me saying that
actually
this requires broader behavioral change
it requires
traffic calming which the council has
implemented along new street in the past
and a range of other measures to deal
with the highest speed travelers
down the road so so the work is underway
the assessment is being undertaken this
will be considered and if it is one of
the schemes that is taken forward after
that assessment has been made there will
be a 20 mile per hour speed limit there
but what i would say is that if there
are more significant concerns about high
speed of vehicles traveling down there
then i will pick up a conversation with
greater manchester police also because
clearly that needs to be dealt with so
chair as counselor had said set out this
will be given consideration if it meets
the prioritization process as an
approved approvable scheme for um this
year then it will be implemented but of
course we do need to consider this in
the round as one of many schemes that
have come forward the challenge that i
would make to the responses that we have
heard is that yet again we have the
green group coming to council saying
stuff doesn't cost money when it does
and sadly if 20 mile per hour
implementation was free we would have
done it that is not the case and so we
move forward with the prioritization of
schemes as set out thank you chair
thank you leader and thank you again to
mr padmore sorry ms padmore and mr
mobiley for presenting your petition
this evening and i hope you go away
thinking that as has been said due
consideration will be given to it
we move to item 5 which is the second
petition new trafford cycle route
and we have which receives 637
signatures to investigate and create a
tfgm news cycle route using the
redundant rail tracks between sail
britannia road and trafford bar talbot
road
again with the arrangements for dealing
with petitions i will now invite mr
jeffrey dencham to introduce the
petition and he has five minutes to
present that thank you thank you very
much good evening ladies and gentlemen
uh
i formally worked on the berry
altringham metrolink line design
development back in 1989 1990
i've spent all of my working life on
transportation systems so i've got
some some background to it
now i like the idea of integrated
transportation corridors but from the
experience of other country corridors i
see that the experience the way we use
shared space in the uk doesn't really
work very well
smaller and slower modes of
transportation are intimidated
by faster or larger modes
lorry drivers often intimidate car
drivers car drivers intimidate cyclists
cyclists intimidate pedestrians
i speak as a car driver a cyclist and a
pedestrian here
recent developments on cycle
pedestrian mix have also of concern
during the pandemic there have been a
fifty percent increase the number of pet
dogs and therefore the number of
pedestrians with dogs walking along
shared routes
a lot of these dogs have not been to
socializing or training classes because
of the pandemic so they do tend to
wander around rather
and also more pedestrians are wearing
earbuds and are unaware of other users
on the shared space
so i believe that separation of
different modes reduces intimidation and
conflict
that's all very well saying that but
what available unused space is there in
this area well it so happens that the
old tracks three and four
which run from britannia road sail to
talbot road trafford bar were lifted in
1963.
previously these two tracks provided for
the semi-fast trains from liverpool and
chester all the way through
to
central to central station and i believe
that these two routes could provide a
dedicated cycle route
now the challenge is
old trafford
station will need some management
because a lot of people come out there
the metrolink substations which are
along that route will cause some
narrowing of the route in places but the
substations are pretty small
security particularly late at night
is an issue
but you can use the metrolink line and
the canal as natural barriers to improve
security
there are limited access points
but it's no worse for any alternative
for those that live on the east side of
any of these current routes and it will
cost money sorry all infrastructure
costs money
but the advantage is
you get a straight route which is 4.6
kilometers long
the cyclists are nowhere near polluting
internal combustion engines
i believe it would be dedicated to
cyclists
and because of all the bridges which are
on the route there would be few crossing
points with other
user types which would cause conflict
now manchester has a good reputation for
reusing redundant victorian structures
our central station was converted to gmx
the dean's gate viaduct has recently
been repurposed as sky park
and i believe this could be a new cycle
facility using the redundant rail tracks
which would be a benefit for the people
of trafford thank you very much for
listening
thank you mr dentium um councillor
williams as the executive member with
responsibility for transport strategy i
invite you now to respond on behalf of
the labour group
thank you chair firstly please allow me
to express um my thanks to mr dunchum uh
for his role in organizing this petition
and for taking the time this evening to
attend full council to introduce the
item before members um it really is very
much appreciated and i welcome the
recent increase in dialogue between
residents and councillors which we've
observed in this forum through the use
of mechanisms such as petitions
traffic council is currently in the
final stages of developing an active
travel strategy to inform future
decisions and investment aimed at
improving walking cycling and other
forms of wheeling across the borough
this administration is committed to
making the comfortable and safe use of
pavements highways and open spaces as
possible as accessible as possible to as
many residents as possible
this petition suggestion for a dedicated
cycle route between betraney road in
sale and tolbert road in stratford will
be considered for inclusion in that
strategy alongside other routes that
weren't consideration
there's a number of cycle routes are
already prioritized for development by
the mayor's challenge fund program any
new routes such as this would need to be
dependent upon the availability of
funding the funding used to date has
been secured by a greater manchester
combined authority and as such it's
spend in the nature and design of the
projects to which it's allocated it's
not the sole decision of trafford
council um so if i can be cheeky mr
dunchem please allow me to um suggest
that that's added to your list of
challenges there
now offices from the council's place
director have advised that there are
likely to be land ownership issues and
other constraints to deal with in
respect of the route that is suggested
in the petition and as such it will
require development in partnership with
transport for greater manchester owing
largely due to its close proximity to
the metrolink line
this said many residents will be aware
of this administration's commitment to
improving the cycle infrastructure
across the border and i'm able this
evening to provide a brief update
of upcoming projects
there were temporary measures introduced
along the a56 during the first lockdown
implemented by central government and
much of that provision has remained in
place since
traffic council is working in
partnership with transport for greater
manchester to bring forward bespoke
cycle lane provision between stratford
and the city centre as well as between
stratford and charlton connecting to
routes that have previously been
delivered along tolbert road and the
manchester trafford northern border
these improvements will be delivered in
phases with some of the very first work
already having commenced at the northern
tip of chester road as part of our
routine highway maintenance programme
a second round of consultation will
shortly be undertaken to introduce
proposals specifically related to
stratford which have been drafted on the
basis of over 16 000 pieces of feedback
from the first round of consultation
work is intended to begin at the end of
the year and delivered over the next
couple of years until fully permanent
measures can be realized during the
regeneration of stratford town centre
i share this update on our existing
projects i hope to convey that this
administration is ambitious about
improving active travel
we will be um
installing new cycle hire schemes as
part of the b network which is being
rolled out across greater manchester and
will complement those routes by
accessing as many improvement
opportunities as possible
the approach that has been taken today
in forming proposals to increase active
travel has been one that has emphasized
engaging with local residents
this is guided work around proposals for
routes along the a56 for the amsterdam
active travel neighborhood and for the
walton road estate low traffic
neighborhood
there's also plans to deliver a safer
cycling group connecting sail town
centre and sail more
these projects are going to take time to
come to realization but together they
represent an ambitious vision and amount
to millions of pounds worth of
investment
this administration is committed to
working with residents and strongly
believes that the best possible policy
decisions are made when local people can
feed their views into the local
decision-making process
thank you thank you councillor williams
that's uh that's your time um
do we have a speaker please on behalf of
the conservative group
councillor ms blackburn thank you
uh thank you mr mayor i will be brief um
we are supportive of this petition um i
think the a56 cycle way has not been um
popular and to have cyclists going on a
disused railway track which has been
misused because of the beaching in the
early 60s
would it would be safer for cyclists and
it would also um be better for
for the motorists because there's been a
lot of
congestion on on the a56 particularly
because of the narrowing of the of the
main road at certain points
obviously um we've got to consider as a
council we have to consider
financial implications in anything and
any
any administration has has to consider
that
um
it's it's it's always important for
young people to learn to cycle
and um
if
it is a safe route then that's that is
wonderful i grew up cycling because
there weren't many cars and that was a
very long time ago
these days we've not only got um um sort
of uh
sort of uh no you know not normal sort
of uh transport you know such as cars
buses heavy goods vehicles to contend
with but we also have these
electric scooters that are very
dangerous and are all all over the place
with with with no
well they don't they don't sort of seem
to think about the impact they'll have
have on everybody so we do support it
but obviously it'll be then be decided
by this administration as to whether
notice can fit in with budgets thank you
mr mayor
thank you councillor miss blackburn uh
is there a speaker to respond on behalf
of liberal democrat group councillor
brophy thank you mayor
and thank you so much to uh mr denshon
for coming to traffic council today with
this really excellent petition and well
done on collecting
637 signatures that's an amazing feat to
have done so on behalf of the liberal
democrat group i'd like to welcome this
petition to investigate creating a new
cycle route along these redundant
railway tracks that run alongside the
current tram lines
so the liberal democrat group we
investigated this extensively when we
saw the petition
and we think this route can be made
viable
in fact some of our older timpani
residents tell us they remember using
this second now redundant track for
regular rail trips into manchester
so this part of the route should be used
again
in fact myself and councillor minis both
as regular cyclists would use it
ourselves as i'm sure many of the others
councillors around here would use it as
well as a safe alternative to the a56 or
the crowded towpath that you mentioned
and i do agree that pedestrians do have
often have their earpieces in and they
don't hear you coming along when you're
on a bike so definitely the proposal to
separate out cyclists along this very
busy route would be welcome
we think it should be referred to as
the councillor lead executive member
mentioned to the greater manchester
authority to have a look at and perhaps
the b network as well to take up the
idea and look at the proposals to
implement this excellent petition so
once again
thank you mr dentium for bringing this
excellent petition to full council today
you have our
support
thank you councillor brophy do we have
someone to speak on behalf of the green
party
councillor welcome thank you and uh
thank you to mr denshon and to everybody
who signed this petition
what to what this position demonstrates
more than anything is that people in
trafford are desperate for decent
cycling infrastructure this petition got
over 600 signatures in just a few days
another petition for safe cycle lanes on
the a56 received over 1200 so actually
quite popular council of blackburn
it just goes to show that the demand is
there
in a society facing multiple challenges
be it global heating obesity or the cost
of living more and more people are
finding that cycling holds the answers
for the everyday challenges they face
and the principles that they believe in
look around the two and three world
economy is burgeoning there's an
explosion in the diversity of rides
available inventive e-bikes in all
shapes and sizes
adaptive bikes and try trikes soon to be
legalized e-scooters going to be
legalized by a conservative government
council of blackburn
and then there are the companies large
and small turning to pedal power for
cheaper and more efficient last mile
deliveries but what's holding us back in
trafford a lack of safe infrastructure
does this petition form part of the
solution to be honest it's impossible to
say without a detailed feasibility study
of the proposal or information about
whether the route might again carry
trams or trains in the future
in principle the green group would be
delighted to see multiple cycle routes
developed when
when we build it in trafford they come
as a success of the trans-pennine trail
bridgewater way and talbot road
investments has shown
but we acknowledge that there are
challenges in resources and capacity to
design and build we already have a
production line of schemes that promise
much but are desperately slow to be
delivered trafford absolutely needs to
focus on the schemes that will be the
most transformational
schemes that link communities and go
where people want to go
we need to back schemes that are easily
accessible to all
and where riders of all ages and gender
feel safe riding alone no matter what
time of day or what time of year the
canal path doesn't provide this and
there must be questions about whether
another scenic but isolated scheme will
either
so let's put it plainly safe permanent
cycle lanes down the a56 linking the
north and south of the borough must be
the priority only they will form the
active travel spine from which other
routes can feed anything else will be a
half measure and half measures won't get
us near the government's ambition to
double cycling rates let alone get us
towards the cycling rates of the
netherlands where one third third of all
journeys are by bike and let's remember
that most of trafford is built on a
plane ideal cycling territory
so the green group looks forward to
hearing the administration's
transformational plans for the a56 which
we here are nearly ready to be consulted
upon for a second time we also look
forward to the publication of the
borough's walking and cycling plan much
promised
and hopefully nearly delivered
let's get the fundamentals in place and
then we can dare to dream for more thank
you
thank you councillor welton um please
can the leader of the council now
summarize for the council and our guest
what will happen with this petition
thank you chair and thank you to this
potential
for bringing the petition strong
agreement probably unusually for me with
councillor welton actually
the
um the position that we are in
here is that we have a scheme that has
come forward that has significant
potential it's not without its
challenges um clearly the entry point is
in my ward i know this spot well i think
that the two principal concerns that i
have as it were to go through a
prioritization process and to give you
an assurance we absolutely will put this
scheme forward as one for
consideration
is one of security which is
very very significant i think but also
when we talk about access and inclusion
for all residents the lack of entry and
exit points here creates
a particularly interesting proposition
as a high speed option um but does not
join us up and connect us up
in um the most
um
exciting of ways in terms of assessing
uh the potential to unlock that
that said there is um funding available
in greater manchester
for um these schemes we will put it
forward for consideration along with um
a number of other schemes that we
are currently looking at if it is
successful when it goes through that
work um that then i would be pleased to
see it come forward i do have those
concerns which make me question where it
will sit
in the grand scheme of prioritization
but actually um it is untapped potential
at present so i will be interested to
see
the results of that work from transport
for greater manchester thank you chair
thank you
leader and thank you again
mr dentium for
bringing this petition with all its
almost 700 signatures to our attention
to the council meeting this evening
we move to item six asset investment
strategy
2022 update this is an update on the
asset investment strategy and i invite
councillor patel executive member for
economy and regeneration to introduce
the report thank you councillor patel
since its establishment in 2017 the
asset investment strategy has been
updated several times we regularly
review and update the strategy to ensure
the council continues to access the best
investment opportunities and that
exposure to risk is appropriate
as a council we engage in investment
activity through two routes direct
investment into property though over
recent years we have greatly reduced our
focus in this area in favor of
development or debt lending that's the
financing of developments through the
provision of funding which in many cases
helps bring about or accelerates or
accelerates development
this investment provides a good risk
adjusted return and can support our
regeneration aspirations for the borough
as outlined by my colleague councillor
ross earlier the financial pressures
facing us as a council are stark and our
investment portfolio brings in millions
of pounds we wouldn't secure from
anywhere else
we are seeking approval today for an
update to our asset investment strategy
to allow our investment management board
with the support of the investment
advisor of our investment advisor some
flexibility around development lending
investments
this change will allow us on a
case-by-case basis to consider
investment opportunities that sit
outside current hard investment
parameters
but where risk elsewhere in the business
case is reduced
these changes will allow the investment
management board more flexibility around
which developments it wants to support
within within the same overall risk
within the report from section 2.6 there
are three examples where this change in
approach will allow us to engage this
flexibility where risk exposure is
reduced elsewhere in a proposal
for members who want a bigger insight
into the investment strategy please do
have a look at the appendix report from
our investment advisors cbre which is
written in a very clear and
understandable way
i would like to reiterate that these
changes do not allow the investment
management management board to increase
the overall risk taken within the
portfolio the council will not be
exposed to any more risk
as a result of these changes we will
just have more flexibility to respond to
sustainable investment opportunities as
they arise
finally i'd like to draw members
attention to section three on governance
to reiterate the robust and independent
scrutiny and auditing of our investment
strategy and decision-making process
thank you
thank you councillor patel is that
seconded please secondary chair has had
the right thank you thank you leaders
do any counselors wish to speak on this
council
is there any more we've got one hand at
the moment just one
in which case councillor
murder
the floor is yours
thank you um i profess at the outset i'm
not familiar with the intricacies of
finance
and i suspect a number of us here aren't
either but there are some principles
which we are all familiar with
the first principle is that investments
whether they are in property currency
lending or other commodities can go up
as well as down we've all had that
before
and the second principle that we're also
all aware of is that
the
greater the risk of an investment the
greater the likelihood of returns
whereas on the other hand the lower the
risk of an investment
the lower the likely returns and so
those two principles are the ones that
we need to apply to ourselves and so we
look at who we are
what we have and
where is it we operate now we're not
investors here
working on the stock market or in
investment banks we're elected public
officials
and the money we have isn't from a
private fund it's not my money or your
money it's public money and the sphere
in which we operate
is where we operate in the public sector
competing with the private sector and
it's precisely for those reasons why
when
investing public money there is a
requirement to exercise caution and
prudence and why
some five years ago in 2017 it was
agreed and approved by this council to
set up and an asset investment strategy
supported by an investment management
body
now the purposes of that was for
carefully structured parameters to be
set out and they are helpfully set out
in the uh a gender item
now i for one believe that the
parameters set out there
are not prescriptive as suggested to the
council but rather very generous
and i'll give some examples the minimum
return expected is two and a half
percent that is very low
the maximum loan to value is 70 percent
not 80 or 90 percent but rather a
generous loan to value
and the transaction rates here are
substantial the targeted transaction is
20 million pounds with a minimum being
10 million pounds and so i then turned
to the evidence in the report
and there's absolutely none i would have
liked to see a suggestion well because
of the structure that we have we've
missed out on six developments which had
a value of 15 million pound on average
90 million pounds worth of investment
which would have brought us profit of
say 10 million pounds and this is very
restrictive
and it's and we're missing out an
investment opportunity there is no
empirical evidence there are no examples
there set out of actual opportunities
missed instead we have hypothetical
three examples set out there well that's
not sufficient when we're acting here as
elected public officials with public
money
and so
i urge uh the council not to approve the
proposal which is actually for
investments to be permitted outside the
very generous and carefully drafted
parameters set out
and for us all to act in not in our
political interests but
the public interest we're dealing with
substantial public money here
thank you all right thank you councillor
mercer that was the only member wishing
to speak so uh the report has as we know
been moved and seconded can it be agreed
please
thank you
don
what do you want charlene's or something
the item seven updated planning
committee code of practice is a report
of the executive member for economy and
regeneration
proposing updates to the planning
committee code of practice which has
been recommended by the planning and
development management committee please
can councillor patel introduce and move
this report thank you very much
councillor patel
apologies i was just a bit distracted
there
thank you chair
our planning team is one of the busiest
in greater manchester we are a borough
that's open for business business which
recognizes our planning system as a
valuable and important interface with
both our residents and developers it's
important that the system we operate is
fair and transparent and the decisions
we take are robust lawful and defendable
this update to our code of contact was
approved by the planning committee
earlier this month and seeks to reflect
changes to the operation of the
committee since the code was first
introduced in 2017 and formalises some
existing common practice
it is relevant to members of the
planning committee our offices and more
widely to the all members here if you
engage with our planning team through
representing residents or calling in
applications please take time to read
this document as it provides useful
guidance on the relevance and nature of
your representations at planning
committee
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank our hard-working planning teams
who who work tirelessly to provide a
great service i would particularly like
to recognize the challenges they
overcame throughout the covey lockdowns
i would like also to extend this thanks
to our equally hard-working planning
committee members if you serve or have
served on the planning committee you
will recognise the commitment it takes
and the responsibility that comes with
it thank you
thank you uh councillor patel is that
seconded please
secondly chair thank you do any members
wish to speak on this report i'm aware
it came to the previous council meeting
has gone back to planning and been
approved there and it's been approved in
many ways already so
do any
councillors actually wish to speak i
suspect not in which case
do we approve this report all right
thank you
item 8 greater manchester clean air
planned july 2022 update
please with the executive member for
climate change and transport strategy
like to introduce the next item which
provides an update on greater
manchester's clean air plan council
williams please thank you
thank you chair the report essentially
provides an update as to
recent developments with the clean air
plan as members will be aware
this work is largely coordinated by
greater manchester uh combined authority
however it is
the statutory responsibility of the
local authority
members will be aware that there have
been a proposal to introduce a charging
zone and the combined authority have now
revised that position and are submitting
to government a proposal to have an
investment led cleaner zone which does
not include any charging component and
this matter is now sat with government
for a response thank you chair
thank you councillor williams the report
is for information is that seconded
please
secondary chair and reserved the right
to speak thank you
do any members wish to speak on this
report
council of coggins anybody else
just one councillor coggins the floor is
yours
thank you mayor i'll be brief um
we're now four years on from when the
government lost its third court case
about illegal levels of air pollution
that we're living with and as you can
see we are back now with a brand new
plan and whilst there are many elements
that we welcome such as electrification
of some buses and calls to stop out of
um area taxis which we have discussed
here before um it is a problem um
there are many elements to welcome but
it does feel yet again that this is a
lost opportunity and this plan could be
so much more ambitious
and this plan really is largely about
waiting for the problem to work itself
out as people stop driving older cars
over the next few years now that we have
a few extra years uh before the deadline
and it did seem like we've said this
before in the green party that we'd like
to see some ambition for something above
the bare legal minimum
that's not all we're asking for our
residents just
legally breathable air
and we know the cities around the world
are making changes to make it easier for
people to move around without depending
on cars for short journeys places like
oslo even starting to ban cars all
together from their city centers there
were so many things that we could do and
it seems that the argument in this is
based on a false dichotomy it seems to
be saying that we can either support
residents through the cost of living
crisis or take immediate and ambitious
steps to clean our air but not both
and now
in the green party we see actually
synchronicities between these two things
we don't see them as being at odds with
one another we know that actually by
enabling people to move around by
walking cycling and scooting we will be
cleaning our air and also enabling
people to get around cheaply and making
their lives easier so i'm afraid
for from us we welcome the fact that it
is here and that it is a plan but we
would like to see more ambition that
we're not just talking about having the
bare legal minimum of clean air by 2026
but they were talking about tackling all
our different types of air pollution our
congestion problems the impacts that has
on our economy our road safety issues
and of course the climate crisis thank
you
uh thank you councillor coggins wood
councillor williams or councillor weston
wish to
comment on that
thank you chair i i just want to
briefly make clear to councillor coggins
and it is frustrating to have to do so
again
that we have very clear parameters
upon which we can embark upon this clean
air plan we are legally directed to use
the resources that come out of central
government for this purpose to deliver
legal levels of nitrogen dioxide
emissions at the roadside
so this i have always said is very
limited in scope but that is not the
beginning and end of greater
manchester's ambitions in this regard we
have as you said progress on the
delivery of zero emission buses we have
the one billion pound crsts
funding we have the b network we have
the cycle schemes that we discussed
earlier this is part of a much more
comprehensive suite of work in this area
all of which will contribute in due
course along with
national interventions such as the
electrification of rail to improving our
air quality it is absolutely critical
that we recognize that yes this plan is
limited in scope but it is not the
beginning and end of our work in greater
manchester on air quality thank you
thank you councillor weston the report
is for information
can it be noted please
all right thank you um we were a little
while ago ahead of schedule we're now
behind it so the next two items can we
be as brief as possible
going through them they are each
items to be noted so item nine
accounts an audit committee's annual
report for 2021-22
and i invite the chair of the committee
council of brotherton to introduce the
report
thank you chair members can read the
report if they want i'll just move it
i'd just like to thank uh the members of
the committee for their work during the
year
the uh the officers um graham bentley
and mark
foster and their staff and the external
auditors who've all been very helpful
during the year i think chair mr mayor
you were a member for part of this year
so i thank you you too
the report is for information is it
seconded
seconded thank you and uh do any
counsellors wish to speak we've all seen
the report in which case it's for
information please can it be noted
thank you item 10
uh i invite a
councillor ross to present year-end
corporate report on health safety and
well-being under whose portfolio this
lies thank you
thank you mayor this report highlights
work undertaken through the pandemic an
overview of incident data and ongoing
health and safety delivery
data for accidents are shown in tables
five and six incidents have risen from
69 last year to 158
that number is comparable to the year
2019 20
where there was 150 36 accidents but
higher in particularly in relation to
schools violence and aggression has
accounted for the most incidents
physical assault totaling 97 instance
again most evident within our schools
when staff were dealing with challenging
behavior
the pandemic impact may be a factor on
behavioural issues level of incidents in
schools will be an area for focus during
the school audits as part of the sla
arrangements in this current year in
conclusion the report has highlighted
the continued work that's been delivered
in response to covert pandemic to safely
reintegrate our work force back to our
main buildings and we will now refocus
on supporting services in schools in a
back to basics approach for 2223. thank
you matt
thank you councillor ross the report is
for information is that seconded please
secondary right do any members wish to
speak uh we've got councillor myers
anybody else and councillor blackburn
briefly i hope
councillor myers
yes i'll be very brief mr mayor
um a worrying factor of course is the 32
incidents which took place
in community schools and can ask
the report itself suggests that the
pandemic is partly responsible for that
increase
and that it would be dealt with
when we do
audits within the sla i'm not sure if
all our community schools have slas with
us to deal with that so can i ask what
will be done with those that don't have
any slas and what additional method
activities will be put into place thank
you mr mayor do you want to take that
question now councillor ross and
i take the second question as well from
councillor ms blackburn
thank you pardon thank you mr matt i
just wanted clarification if that's
possible um
4.2.1 um it's uh
it states that there were
52
incidents in relation to the special
schools
and i wondered um do any of these
numbers include the passenger assistance
on the home to school transport and in
4.2.4
um 10 reported incidents and and then it
it it
details transport provision so are the
the ten included in with the um the 52
thank you
thank you mayor
sorry well yeah sorry council ross would
you like to respond yeah sorry thank you
thank you very much um to council myers
i think you you raise a good point and
we need to know what's happening in
those schools that don't have our sla
i'll feed that back to our health and
safety team and we'll find out but we'll
halfway through this this this current
year will bring a report which will give
updates on on the challenging behavior
in the the abusive schools as well so
hopefully we'll feed through into that
um
as far as i'm i'm concerned yes it does
include home to school transport again
but i'll get that clarity for you
outside of this meeting thank you
council blackman thank you thank you
councillor i expected you would be able
to take that
question offline to provide an answer to
councillor ms blackburn um
anyone else speaking
leader no in which case
it is
for
information can it be noted please this
report thank you item 11
motions um and i would reiterate what i
said earlier about keeping your speeches
as brief as you can and as succinct as
you can and certainly
not repeating anything that any other
previous member has already said so with
three motions listed in the order in
which they received
[Music]
motion 11a
proceeding then with the first motion
regarding save our rivers i've received
notice that is be moved by council of
frash please
thank you thank you mr mayor this motion
will be particularly important to the
residents of defects nevertheless i will
endeavor to keep to about three minutes
instances of flash flooding in timpani
and indeed across trafford used to
happen maybe once or twice a decade
people's homes being flooded is now an
occurrence that we can expect to witness
twice a year
my residence on fairborn drive woodhouse
lane my residents and sweyland and hayes
lane are now used to seeing their local
brook burst its banks with alarming
frequency
time and again these residents are told
by the environment agency by the council
and by its contractors that flooding in
timperley is just not the priority
when resources are so stretched and
nobody but nobody can attend maybe until
the next day people have turned to my
liberal democrat colleagues colleagues
of whom i can proudly say did not let
them down not least last january when
water entered several homes in timperley
it was left to the lib dems who were
literally helping residents hurriedly
stack sandbags to hold back the rising
water
hard evidence if any still needed that
the real consequences of the climate
emergency are already here
so every opportunity must be taken to
crack down on environmental injustice
especially at a time when we've all seen
government ministers and mps
demonstrate such indifference towards
our natural world
this environmental injustice i speak of
mr mayor is not just people suffering
consequences of climate change
it is also the very health of the
ecosystems in our rivers and brooks
sewage dumping has become endemic across
britain all the species of plants of
fish and of insect life now hang
in the balance their water is polluted
toxins are building up and they're dying
off
we have a government which actively
allows utility companies to dump
untreated sewage in our waterways we
have a government that has cut the
funding for water quality inspection by
75 percent and we have ourselves got
used to watching the government defend
the indefensible
i saw with my own eyes the most
effective short-term measure to stop
homes flooding when in december last
year residents once again called the
liberal democrats this time storm barrow
threatened to bring the flood waters to
their door
at midnight as the water levels rose we
realized that flooding could be avoided
if only we could get the agency out in
time to unblock debris under a
particular bridge and let that storm
water go through
the good relations my colleagues had
built up with the agency the environment
agency meant that we got a team out and
by 1 am december was not a repeat of
january
so we should all support this motion
because it commits the council's
flooding resilience group to beef up the
level of maintenance i can tell you that
makes all the difference we should all
support this motion because the mps who
voted against proposals to stop sewage
dumping
were wrong
those 265 conservative mps did not
understand how angry people feel about
this there is a storm sewage outlet into
the very brook which keeps flooding
these homes
so finally i must remind you all we
cannot let our residents suffer the foul
consequences of flooding water entering
people's homes i'm moving this motion
and we must send the right message
tonight
thank you council of frash
is
the motion seconded
thank you mr mayor i want to second this
motion by reminding the council that
pollution and flash flooding have real
human consequences when councillor
newgrass and i responded to reports of
flooding in timperley last january we
met with several families affected
first there was a family with water
levels rising to waist height at their
back door as they struggled to fill
sandbags they could have easily been
forgiven for prioritizing their own home
but they didn't miss the mayor they made
time to check on their neighbours and
even lent their water pump out to others
who were affected
and further up the road we met residents
who had no electricity they were
frustrated because they couldn't seem to
get anybody on the phone no answer from
the council none from the environment
agency none from any of the emergency
helplines
just next door to them one family had
been preparing for the funeral of a
loved one due to take place the
following day when the waters came into
the home
we stood together mostly in silence
pushing water towards drains with garden
brushes
and just a few doors up the road again
there was an 84 year old woman living
alone
she said i've just lost my husband to
coronavirus please make sure i don't
lose my home as well
there are reasons why timpery was not a
priority in january and we're mindful of
them the crew we needed were tied up in
disbury services are overstretched and
underfunded
at a meeting of the event with the
environment agency timperley residents
were pleased to hear that things will
slowly start to move in the right
direction when it comes to flood
defences but at that same meeting it was
clear that the environment agency is
working on outdated modelling which did
not anticipate serious flooding risk
along fairwell brook
maintenance schedules and general health
checks all rely on that outdated
modelling so it's clear that there is a
gap in our emergency planning when it
comes to flash flooding and we must
continue to revise our approach this
motion seeks to address that
but imagine the anger felt by the
residents i met when they found out that
those flood waters are being polluted by
our water companies
as local leaders we must champion
environmental justice and call for a
sewage tax on the profits of polluters
i was hoping for agreement across the
chamber on that point before i saw the
tory amendment because the idea is a
simple one if you pollute rivers you
should be punished for it
fine words and high ideals on the
environment count for nothing if we
don't make it hurt when companies harm
our natural world
but sadly we have a conservative
government that has gone out of its way
to strip environmental protections from
recent legislation
including sir graham brady
who voted along with 264 of his
conservative colleagues to allow sewage
dumping to go unchallenged
if conservatives could show as much
enthusiasm for supporting flooded
residents as they do for protecting sir
graham's good name simply residents
would be a lot better served
mr mayor recent weeks have been a lesson
to us all about the effects of severe
weather as councilor frass has said
we've seen some of the worst effects of
climate change are already with us
we have also seen the need to prepare
and reinforce our emergency response i
am sure we will face many many more
instances of flash flooding and severe
weather in the years to come
the liberal democrats want to do all in
our power working across this chamber
with our officers and with those and
other services to make sure our
residents do not face on certain nights
in the future
so in summary clean and healthy rivers
and brooks regularly looked after by the
experts and kept safe from pollution
that's what our residents expect mr
mayor everybody should support this
motion
thank you councillor ennis i i have
received notice of an amendment to this
motion and i therefore invite councillor
morgan to move this now please thank you
thank you mr mayor going to keep this
brief um as supported by the independent
fact-checkers the original lord's
amendment in parliament would have cost
households up to 25 grand a year each um
and also the time to raise funding
through the search tax um to raise 340
million pounds a year
um would take up to a millennium
so
just in summary when the liberal
democrat leader
was environment secretary he didn't
implement it which probably indicates
that it's not such an easy solution that
is now
stating thank you
thank you councillor morgan is the
amendment seconded
speaking are you reserving a right to
speak council admirers
listen to what's being said mr mayor
thank you um right um
does any councillor now wish to speak
right
councillor freeman
and councillor weston anybody else um i
think i saw
councillor freeman first of all and we
are being briefed thank you yes but i'm
going to be brief chair thank you
four years ago on this very day i lost
my sister twin sister to lung cancer
caused by air pollution
she never smoked we only get one world
and it's incumbent on us all to do our
best to preserve it for future
generations the amendment from the
tories is absolutely typical of them
trying to gaslight their own
government's failure on the environment
in that they seek to actually remove
fact from the from the original motion
and give their awful tory mp mr brady a
get out as a party of government the
tories are failing us all on the
environment on environmental issues when
will locally elected tourists wake up to
this and grow their own backbone vote
this amendment down thank you
thank you councillor freeman council of
western
i found that he doesn't wish to speak
um so we have the amendment proposed
and seconded does council and myers wish
to say anything at all
um i don't think so mr mayor i don't
think much uh much light's been added to
this
thank you right in that case we vote on
the
amendment oh right
sorry council of frass the original
proposer has a right to speak
on the amendment
briefly the freedom of information has
revealed uh severe underfunding of the
environment agencies being catastrophic
for the health of rivers so
concealing that information as the
conservative group has tried with the
amendment is perhaps not helpful
having the references to sewage and
chemicals struck off the motion will not
mean that that pollution disappears from
our water courses thank you
thank you council of france we can now
put the amendment to the vote
all those in favor of the amendment
and all those against
i think the amendment fails so we go
back to the original motion as the
substantive motion
does anybody now wish to speak on that i
know councillor i'd said does
anybody else
um
right that's councillor
lester is it i think
right um councillor ad said
i've got some uh helpful information
from the environment age but i'll just
first let's just uh comment on council
has comment but we will be supporting
emotion
obviously but i am concerned at his
comments in relation to actually how uh
the council's uh didn't see it as
surprised this is simply not true the
date on some of the events that happened
there was storm force date there was
threat to life across many areas of the
brother and they have to be a priority
so threatening life against people's
guard has been flooded you know there is
no simply no choice in that so i make no
apologies and our officers uh partners
and these many councils out there
working they were knocking on people's
doors warning that there was threats to
their life so i think you know we have
to put this into perspective in that
sense of it and that people's life are
in danger we have to prioritize that
against people's uh gardens being
flooded so you know having said that
though we will be supporting motion and
this is to do with all three climate
change and we can expect much more of
this uh so i just want to say uh give
them the time uh and i know there's two
more amendments yet i will send you over
in a minute or so now some helpful
information from the environment age in
which they will be willing to take out
some more work in in that area so
hopefully you'll find that helpful but
given the time it's probably a bit too
long to comment i'm sure the mayor would
probably pull me up for that they did
that's hopefully yeah i'll try and pass
it over in a minute you might want to
look at it that find it helpful thank
you
thank you councillor had said councillor
lester he wanted to speak thank you
thank you mayor um in february 2020
after heavy rains and shortly before the
lockdown i went on a litter-picking
session in an area locally known as
armstrong beach on the river mersey
which is a popular spot for families to
walk and visit
when i arrived i was horrified but
hanging from the trees was i was
presented with sanitary wear nappies and
a lot worse there's a group of people
clearing the area we could only scratch
the surface of the problem
this is the reality of raw sewage being
discharged from the storm overflows into
our rivers
as the river trust states the rivers of
the front line of our climate and nature
christ
are on the front line of our climate and
nature crisis globally the wildlife
populations in the freshwater ecosystems
are suffering losses greater than those
observed in any other habitat
to adapt to and recover from climate
shocks we need healthy rivers
in 2021 in strepford the sewer storm
overflowed overflow spilled 91 times for
a total of 12
1231 hours discharging into the river
mersey and in my ward of hail central
the park road our fog road sewer storm
overflowed spilled uh 144 times for 764
hours discharging into the river bowling
and going forwards more extreme rainfall
is going to result in more frequent
sewage discharges and less actions taken
to rescue our rivers and watercourses
changes need to be made to how water
land and develop and development is
managed
much of this needs to be led at a
national level but we need local action
as well
including working with united utilities
and holding them to account in their
duty to reduce
sewage discharges and working with local
charities such as the mersey river trust
who have citizen scientists who are
working as river guardians monitoring
the water quality to highlight
particular areas of concern
and ensuring that the riverbanks are
cleaned if they've been large sewage
sewage discharges
so we need to act up now and we will be
supporting this motion
thank you councillor lester i'm advised
on my left-hand side that counsellor
newgrosh wanted to speak as well briefly
thank you mr mayor i just wanted to
correct council ads head on his comment
about
flooded gardens i was there at storm
kristoff
i was
thigh high in
foul water
moving sandbags and trying to save
homes
the threat to life
it may have been there certainly for the
elderly and vulnerable in those homes we
were lucky very lucky at that time where
the water receded just in time but my
wife bought me waders from that incident
and the next storm i went out and the
environment agency officer next to me
was reticent to walk out onto beach
fields in the dark at one in the morning
and i assured him that he could follow
me and that if i fell you know to my
death he would have a story to tell the
rest of his life
he did follow and he was amazed how
flooded beech fields was and he put that
in his report his the data we have on
how deep it floods there is wrong
and it's that i would love addressing
and that foul water to think we were in
foul water at that time is also
disgusting i just needed that clarified
thank you very much mr man thank you
councillor new gross i think we've now
had sufficient debate on this particular
motion and we are on the substantive
motion as originally proposed
so
could we take a vote all those in favor
those against
and abstentions
thank you
motion 11 b
concerns local government pay and this
is to be moved by
i have a blank on my script here
so it would be be moved by council
slater i just at this point would
got a debate going here between us um
it's councillor ross but i would point
to say at this point that when we come
to
uh
not the main speakers other people if
you've got three minutes prepared you
will not be getting three minutes
because that's where we are time wise on
our agenda so you might want to start
crossing little bits out councillor ross
thank you mayor as a unison member it
gives me great pleasure to move this
motion this evening
we're now in the 14th year of a pay
crisis which has intensified over the
last year by a spike in the rate of
inflation
workers across the country are now being
asked to bear the brunt of global price
rises particularly via energy and food
having already borne the brunt of a
decade of austerity hardship associated
with the pandemic and the longest pay
squeeze since the napoleonic wars
failure to keep up with the rising cost
of living is having a significant impact
on working people's daily lives and
research shows that lower income
households are suffering the most from
rising prices
local government workers deserve a real
terms pay increase and should not have
to choose between food heating and other
essentials particularly after so many of
our council and school staff kept our
communities safe during the pandemic
i'd like to stress a key part of this
motion acknowledges that it is for
central government to take
responsibility and fully fund this
increase
members will be aware already of how
tight local authority budgets across the
country are
i'd also like to highlight the wider
economic benefits of the government
funding of real terms pay increase
consumer demand is already fragile and
we
investment and trade weak
higher pay is therefore important to
stimulate spending in the economy with
those households on lower and medium
incomes having a higher propensity to
spend which also supports our local
economy
as the motion suggests around half of
the cost of this pay rise would be
recovered via increased tax revenues and
reduced expenditure on benefits and tax
credits
members may voice concerned about a
potential inflationary wage spiral and
this is something that has been said in
in large parts of the media but i have
to say i agree with the sound analysis
produced by the economist at the tuc
it is now time to prioritize wage growth
over the growth in the value of assets
held by just a few people many
households are now at the brink and a
pay increase will provide vital support
to individuals families and also to
stimulate flagging demand in our economy
in conclusion this motion caused for the
council to support the pay claims
submitted by unison gmb and unite
calls on the lga to make urgent
representations to central government to
fund the njc claim to write to the
chancellor and secretary of state to
call for a pay increase to be funded
with new money from central government
and to meet with our local njc union
reps to convey support on for the pay
claim thank you mayor
thank you councillor ross i assume the
motion is seconded by
i'm proud to be second in this motion on
local government pay as a local
government worker and also a unison
member i feel i might have to declare an
interest
with year-on-year cuts to council and
school budgets local government schools
and school staff have endured over a
decade of no pay rises or or rises of
one or two percent losing in real terms
25 percent of their pay
with inflation running at 11.8 currently
and likely to rise due to the
mismanagement of the of the economy by
the present government how can we expect
staff to manage with below inflation
rises
central government should be providing
extra funding to councils and schools to
give a real pay rise to those staff who
have kept our services running have
educated our children have provided
social care to our residents and buried
our dead
the motion clearly outlines the massive
importance of staff of our staff in the
community and it's time it was
recognised local government staff are
continuously experiencing ever
increasing workload and job insecurity
across the uk 900 000 jobs have been
lost in local government since june 2010
a reduction of more than 30 percent
women who make up more than three
quarters of the local government
workforce have even have been more
disproportionately disadvantaged over
this period
proven research shows that if government
were to fund that the njc uni union's
2022 pay claim around half the money
would be recouped due to increased taxes
increased tax revenue reduced
expenditure on working tax credits and
increasing consumer spending in our
local communities our staff are our
public service heroes and they deserve
better
local government has arguably been hit
more severely job losses by job losses
than any other part of the public sector
local government has for far too long
been treated as a cinderella service we
need a real leveling up that we were
promised please support the motion
thank you councillor slater
the motion has now been moved and
seconded do any members wish to speak to
it
right mr jerome minis
chalking
i have councillors jerome minis and
chalking in that order others
blackburn
thank you
in which case uh
council of jerome thank you
thank you chair um i'd just like to say
the green group will be supporting this
motion and i agree wholeheartedly with
councillor slater when she says that the
public sector workers have had a pay
free since 2010.
so now with the pay rise pay rises are
well below inflation some of the people
in in most of the hardest and lowest
paid jobs are now in absolute poverty
and if you look in many schools and
hospitals in this in these current times
many of those are starting to put food
banks in their own workplaces just so
some of those staff can can go home and
feed their families we're in an
absolutely appalling situation which is
we've been led there by this this tory
government it's an absolute shock and
absolute crime and um we will be
supporting this motion um and thank you
for bringing it
thank you councillor jerome councillor
minis
thank you chair um i have a declaration
so i'm a unite member um
group and we fully support uh pay rises
for uh workers including those in the
public sector um
we support the public sector pay freezes
which um i i've experienced it since
2010 as well that's an nhs worker um
followed by limited cost of living rises
the pistons of one percent and etceteras
have led to real terms cut in pay
the cost of living crisis that we're
going through now and it's only going to
get worse and drastically worse
will make it impossible for the lower
paid public sector workers to make ends
meet we're fully supportive thank you
thank you council administ councillor
chalking
thank you chad um just try and condense
very quickly what i wrote um
i've i've said this before
fully i'm fully appreciative we are
fully appreciative and we congratulate
staff for all the work they have done
over the past decade
facing the reduction in services that
they've had because of mandatory central
government cuts
they've put up with an awful lot an
awful lot of uncertainty and change and
they've excelled and i agree
we agree with what's in the in the um
motion about them being public service
heroes um
the motion put forward is it admirable
and we do sympathize with the desire to
see people better paid for the work that
they do it's not just about the cost of
living of course it's about attracting
the best of the public service heroes to
come and work in trafford and most
importantly to convince them to stay
traffic has been affected acutely by the
reduction in central government grants
um
and the central government has
recognized that the cutbacks uh have had
an effect and they have committed to
funding local authorities so they can
improve vital frontline services and
protect residents from excessive council
tax risers i did check that one um
i'm not going to pass about the numbers
involved because there will be
derivation from other members but there
has been a four percent increase in real
terms since 2019 in the funding given to
senator to local councils
um
that said we as a group are happy to at
our voice to make sure that promise that
the promise of fair funding is delivered
upon to protect those who dedicate
themselves to our borough
with that all said we find ourselves
unable to support the motion are set out
before us tonight it isn't just because
it's in support of a union pay claim it
but it is because it's calling for
something that's not it can't possibly
deliver on
just taking the first two points the key
points from my perspective
if you assume that about 70 of our
workforce have around the nine percent
increase in salary because that's where
annual rpi is at the moment and it's
that's the lowest of the estimates
crudely translates into a further 430
000 pounds for staff base pay based on
this year's budget and across england
alone that would equate to something
like 143 million pounds that's just on
staff pay
their crudes on scientific figures but
that gives an idea of the scale of just
what's being asked and that money has to
come for they're from somewhere
what i will say there's some some points
made about the effects that that has
that i will disagree though that it's
going to lead to increase in tax revenue
because one's just simply paying for the
other if you want a real effect you've
got to ask for more
and i will take issue with the union um
call for a 35-hour working week with no
reduction in pay we'd all like to work
less but salaries and wages are based on
the time put in and if you do work less
you will be paid less and that's
core to working life i'm sorry
it's it's not up to the government or
the taxpayer to fund somebody who
doesn't want to work as often as
somebody else
if it should be noted that the
government has offered a pay increase of
1 925 pounds on all njc pay points one
and above and a four percent increase in
allowances they've also
just drawn to a conclusion
they've also offered
an additional one day to the annual
leave entitlement which has been asked
for and the deletion of 8.1
um we must sustain from this vote but it
isn't because we don't sympathize with
the underlying reason it's because
what's being asked for is unworkable and
is also being addressed by the
government's increase and funded to
local authorities thank you
thank you councillor chalking councillor
blackburn's requesting to speak as well
um could i just ask for clarification mr
mayor um
do members this evening have to declare
if they are in a union on if if parts of
the you know the motions
certain unions are you know if they
speak to this
if this
my view would be if they speak to the
motion
then they should declare
whether they are a member of unison in
for certain because that specifically is
mentioned in the motion if they wish to
declare membership of another union i
would say that's entirely their business
and i'd also add that
membership of the union is on the
council's website as every member's
declaration of interests or should be if
you are
and if you are and it's not then it
should be thank you um so thank you is
that what you wanted to ask councillor
blackburn
yeah yeah thank you um i know councillor
western wants to add something to this
debate
thank you chair and if it's helpful to
go beyond my declaration of interest i
am a member of unison and very proudly
so i
haven't indicated initially that i wish
to speak but i do need to challenge
councillor chulkin
on his shrugging off of suggested
sympathy for motion and then suggesting
its unaffordability
with no understanding of the
unaffordability of the current crisis
for our staff forget this being in the
round forget this being about
local government pay you know we have
members of staff in this local authority
and you won't know this councillor
choking
who are in tears
in the corridors of this town hall
not knowing how they are going to pay
their bills
we have members of staff
in this council not knowing how they are
going to feed their children
it is not
their fault
that inflation is rocketing
it is not their fault that the
government has lost grip on its economic
policy
and it is not
in their gift to resolve that there are
very very few people in this society who
are able
to withstand
a doubling of their energy bills a
rocketing of fuel prices
record inflation food prices through the
roof and absorb that into their
household budgets you will be aware
councillor chokin that local authorities
are not necessarily low wage payers the
people that i am talking about are not
even necessarily some of our lowest paid
staff and in making the contribution
that you have
i'm so disappointed because you show
yourself to be so detached from the
experiences that they and hundreds of
thousands of other workers in the public
sector in local authorities in this
country find themselves at present
it may
be
unaffordable on your terms councillor
choking but doing nothing is certainly
unaffordable on theirs and that is why i
am so proud to support this motion thank
you chair
thank you uh councillor western and its
uh
debate is now concluded apart from the
council ross has
the opportunity to
make some concluding remarks should he
wish
thank you mayor um i'd first of all like
to thank both councillor jerome and
council minister for your comments and
your support of this motion in your
recognition as the leader has just said
about the real difficulties our members
of staff who are social workers who go
out and collect our ways to go
environmental health ever you know every
aspect of the council who have faced so
much difficulty over the past 12 years
because of ongoing austerity and wage
restraint um i'm really thank you for
your understanding
i
would like to say i admire your valiant
performance there counselor chalking as
you try to square a circle
and uh sound supportive at the same time
as as
well i'll try not to be impolite but you
know not accepting the real pain that
workers are going through i won't want
to say anything harsher than that it did
feel like you were taking us back to
victorian britain though and the um the
the kind of suggestion that people
wanting to uh work on a 35-hour week and
it's um it's it's not kind of acceptable
it's something you know you're
suggesting that they could be quite
steed has been quite lazy with that um i
thought that was really poor you know
the trade unions have been existed for
for centuries um over the 19th and 20th
century in particular anyone let's say
anyone who's been employed or in
employment they will have benefited from
actions and campaigns that trade unions
have put together on behalf of working
people up and down the country and i
have to say i know there are a number of
us in this chamber who are incredibly
proud of the trade union movement
including right now concluding today
with what's going on to um to make sure
that members front line workers key
workers get the respect and dignity work
that they deserve and long may that
continue um i know that the lga have
offered as you as you did say they have
offered um a um a pay um
increase today that will go back to
negotiation now we'll see what happens
with that but um finally in terms of
affordability there are macroeconomic
arguments clear macroeconomic arguments
for central government
honoring a real terms pay increase it
will help the economy which is
absolutely dire straight because of what
this government has been doing for the
past six or seven years and beyond
it's an absolute messy economy at the
moment this kind of thing would
stimulate demand and
make the economy grow again and when i
think of the billions that have been
squandered by this government over the
past few years
you've got no room to talk about what's
affordable or not we need to be putting
money back into our front line workers
pockets so they can rescue this economy
and not be giving back handers to
friends of ministers thank you mayor
thank you
thank you councillor ross and i'll now
put the motion to the vote
all those in favor
all those against
are there any abstentions
thank you
and at least i didn't have to cast a
casting vote because i would have had to
declare an interest being a retired
member of unison and still a retired
member of unison right motion 11c
councillor mercer please can you move
the final motion concerning manchester
airport and we really are very pushed
for time and we've got two clocks that
are divergent with each other
i'm somewhere between the two
mr mayor i move this motion uh which is
titled monster airport passenger
experience is your microphone yeah it is
i do
fine yes
mr mayor i move this motion which is
titled manchester airport passenger
experience
and you'll be aware it concerns aviation
disruption
in fact we're all aware of this we've
read it about it in the national press
we've seen it on national tv
i for one have had a personal poor
experience and i'm sure many of us know
family friends and colleagues who have
all uh suffered bad experiences with the
aviation disruption manchester airport
is of course very precious to us
it is adjacent to trafford it is a major
international airport the fourth busiest
in the uk and acts as a global gateway
for the north of england to the rest of
the world
we of course are fortunate to be a
shareholder in the airport
but that then causes us great concern
both as
a financial financial holder with a
financial interest in the airport but
also as a council
with many citizens who work and operate
through manchester airport
mr mara i can inform you that
the disruption remains ongoing six
months on and we see no reduction in the
lengthy delays large queues abandoned
flights
delayed and lost luggage
in fact of the 26 airports in the uk
during the first three months of the
year manchester airport was
or had the lowest percentage of flights
departing on time
this situation appears to be continuing
it is unsatisfactory in fact i would
argue it's now so many months on it can
only be described as inexcusable
there are you'll note amendments to this
uh motion i won't comment and i can't
specifically on them at this stage
suffice to say that they do not
challenge what i resolve the council to
do and that is a a very simple
agreeable and uncontroversial step and
that is for our chief executive to write
to the managing director of manchester
airport chris woodruff and ask him what
his plans and intentions are to improve
the airport's performance and so
i invite you all to support this motion
uh there will be attempts to uh score uh
political uh points with the amendments
but the ultimate goal of the motion is
is unchallenged and i'm pleased to note
that thank you councilman sir the uh
motion is to be seconded by councillor
miss blackburn i think even at this
point we've got to reduce the main
speakers to an absolute maximum of two
minutes
uh thank you mr mayor um it's late in
the evening and i will be brief i'm
happy to second the motion
um local and national news has
highlighted the awful frustrations that
travel travelers have experienced at
manchester airport
and members of this chamber
all their families um
might have firsthand knowledge of this
and the levels of stress were truly
awful especially where children disabled
or elderly passengers were part of the
travelling group
my own son daughter-in-law and
granddaughters traveled through the
airport last month and i know the issues
that they had
manchester airport flight schedules have
been in place for a considerable amount
of time and passengers booking with
travel companies or airlines paid in
good faith for a long awaited break
following the pandemic
plans should have been in place long ago
to ensure the smooth running of all
services provided trafford as a
shareholder together with other gm
authorities has used its annual dividend
to supplement especially our demand-led
budgets such as children's or adult
social care
and i think this is something that we've
got to consider because we have been
used to that amount of money and it's
been spent prudently
as good traveler experience lessons
other airports will become more
a more favorable choice and this could
also ultimately impact on their profits
our residents use this as their local
airport and are concerned that an
appropriate signal should be sent to the
managing director in order that
insurances are given that they'll be
realistic improvement very soon it is
our residents who we answer to and they
expect us as their local representatives
and as we are a shareholder of the
airport to make their legitimate
concerns known thank you councillor miss
blackburn we have received as you know
two amendments to this emotion the first
of which is from the labour group and
i'd ask councillor patel to move the
first amendment thank you thank you
this amendment seeks to recognize the
impact on passengers of the disruption
at manchester airport but unlike the
original motion looks more widely at the
causes of what is a crisis in our
aviation sector on the 28th of may after
eight miserable hours at manchester
airport i was informed by text message
that my flight and holiday booked nearly
two years ago had been cancelled we
spent a further two hours waiting in a
sea of abandoned luggage before we could
go home a shocking and unpleasant
experience for my family and one that
thousands of others experienced too
it wasn't however manchester airport
that failed to provide a pilot for my
flight or the airport that was
responsible for the baggage chaos it was
tui and swiss port two companies that
announced mass redundancies during 2020
and 2021
it is evidenced by unions that by the
end of 2021
over 60 000 people have lost their jobs
at uk airports firms banking on workers
queuing up outside the door covid have
learned the hard way that loyal trained
staff aren't so disposable after all
people have found better offers better
paying conditions and have been lost by
the aviation industry for good
the beginning of the year was
challenging for manchester airport
delays at security were well documented
caused by shortages in security staff it
was difficult to recruit a process which
was hugely impacted by delays in
necessary government background checks
the managing director of the then
managing director of manchester airport
karen smart took responsibility and
resigned
to understand this poor performance
further however it's got to be viewed in
the context of a sector that was
ill-prepared for the return of air
travel this chaos had been predicted by
the airlines airport operators and
unions
in march 2020 rishi sunap promised an
aviation
sector specific support package it never
materialized throughout the pandemic
labor and the airline industry called on
government to produce a robust plan for
saving jobs in aviation and to realize
the sector support deal it had promised
to retain those skilled security cleared
people and prevent these staff shortages
instead of responding proactively the
government has presided over the
disastrous management of airports
rapid and confusing changes to quality
world and buried its head in the sand
over brexit
thank you uh councillor patel the
amendment has been moved and seconded do
any members wish to speak to this
sorry i'm sorry councillor freeman
you're you're on the page before sorry
i turned the page i formally settled the
amendment i don't intend to speak on it
i think it speaks for itself thank you
very much thank you very much indeed
councillor freeman now the amendment has
been moved and seconded do any members
wish to speak to the amendment
all right just one
okay the floor is yours for probably
about a minute now
thank you chair
the original motion is endemic of the
government's playing game they want the
headlines and failing to follow up
it's a catalogue of rush act without
consulting a complete lack of liaison to
ensure a crucial part of the transport
infrastructure could cope with a very
quick and very short notice opening of
the skies
i wouldn't lasted one month hours an
hour dropping 30 seconds through
security the issue is airports
associated business being oil to recruit
due to security checks imposed by the
government these processes have taken
the same length of time as passports
driving licenses and airtel coming out
of pandemic was difficult obviously but
there's been a lack of cohesive
communications with the sector and the
use of negative press please from
government ministers from the prime
minister and the transport secretary
down
systematically blaming the industry and
absolving themselves again this
amendment offers a collaborative
approach to
chris
to aid putting the correct and proper
measures forward for manchester airport
i only hope other airport airports
benefit from proactive partners we
cannot expect the government to be
involved in proactive talks as his own
blame game now seems to have moved to
the french customs at dover and those
headlines are more pertinent now thank
you thank you councillor um does uh
councillor mercer before we go to a vote
on the amendment wish to respond to the
comments
no it looks like no in which case we go
to a vote on this first amendment all in
favor of the first amendment
those against
any abstentions
right we move to the second amendment
which is i invite councillor ennis to
move the second amendment proposed by
the liberal democrats and you've
probably got
[Music]
somewhere between one and two minutes
thank you mr mayor the liberal democrats
support the aims of this motion as
amended and our amendment stands as an
addition to the current substantive
motion um
as a stakeholder in manchester airport
it's right that the council should have
a regular dialogue with leading figures
i'm very new to this council but as i
understand it invitations have already
been made through the scrutiny committee
for the managing director to come to
trafford
this amendment seeks to contextualize
the problems facing manchester airport
against the backdrop of brexit and the
wider economic recovery post pandemic
every airport in every country in the
world has had to deal with covert only
british airports have had to deal with
brexit as well
we know that airports and airlines now
face challenges in recruitment due to
brexit and this amendment seeks to
reflect that we should also acknowledge
that airports like manchester cut
staffing levels very quickly during the
early onset of the pandemic and this has
exacerbated problems that were already
brewing in the sector again this
amendment reflects that so i hope
colleagues can support the amendment
thank you mr mayor thank you councillor
ennis uh i believe now this is to be
seconded by councillor brophy yeah
thank you mayor seconding the lib dem
amendment so we know that britain's
withdrawal from the european union has
had considerable implications for
staffing at airports and this has been
acknowledged by those who manage the
current airport situation
of course covert did impact but let us
not forget in the year before the
pandemic more than a quarter of a
million eu citizens left the uk mostly
working age citizens in sectors that
involve public-facing jobs
so many of these former airport
employees are finding more favorable
employment in other sectors with more
favorable hours and due to brexit and
poor handling of covid as um councillor
ennis has just said britain is projected
to endure the worst economic recovery in
the g7
now we can't talk about airports and
airlines without considering the carbon
emissions from flying now this is
referred to in our amendment
crucially our council in trafford has
declared a climate emergency
there is onus on central government
airlines airports and stakeholders to
ensure that this sector works towards
our environmental targets to cut carbon
emissions as a top priority and we do
want this recognised in a motion all
about airports thank you
thank you councillor brophy does anybody
now wish to speak to this second
amendment i know councillor western on
my left
anybody up councillor weston thank you
chair just very briefly for clarity i
think council renis said that the
amendment was now to be revised to fit
what is has become the substantive
motion so on that basis and as an
addition to the labour amendment we will
accept this motion and just i think to
recognize the point that council renis
also made
that the
train was already in motion in terms of
inviting
manchester airport colleagues to
scrutiny committee and indeed i have had
direct conversations with members of the
conservative group to that end thank you
chair
right does councillor mirza want to say
anything before we actually come to some
form of a vote on the second amendment
thank you council of mercer so we now do
go for a vote on the second amendment
which is going to be amended to fit with
the labor motion i believe which has now
become the substantive motion so all in
favor of that
anybody
against any abstentions
right so we now have the substantia we
had lots of discussion on this um the
substantive motion now becomes the
the amen the labor motion amended by the
uh lib dems tweaked a little bit before
it's amended so
that right yeah so all in favor of that
emotion
and
all against
i just said we've had a lot of debate
about it
do you wish to speak councillor welton
well actually
if if you can cut it down to less than a
minute you're on so nicolas parsons off
you go
i'll give it a go and uh and i
appreciate your love of procedure
this crisis should be an opportunity to
have a grown-up conversation about the
future of air travel there's no point
guaranteeing good customer service if we
don't at the same time guarantee the
future of our planet thank you very much
have a good evening right so we are we
are now going to go for a vote
on the
liberal democrat amended labor motion
with the level democrat amendment tweet
to suit the labour group
all those in favor
all those against
abstentions
right thank you very much
that then is the end of the meeting i
thank you all for your attendance i
haven't finished quite yet we've still
got 30 seconds left according to my
watch
i hope you enjoy the rest of your
evening
i hope you enjoy the summer that's
coming
i
also invite anybody anybody and
everybody to join me in the mayor's
parlor for refreshments following the
meeting this includes our staff as well
as the members and i can tell you i have
been out to tesco's today with my club
card so
you are very welcome
you